let's go back to the Mana swamp a minus
number it has a significant problem I
tried to fix it I I tried to collab with
people that I thought were good people
that were interested in um you know
getting the message out and improving it
and I saw what the knowledge did for me
that I took I saw what the knowledge did
that I took from Evo psych I saw what
the knowledge uh that I took from
observing behavior from this lens did
for my life and I legitimately wanted to
improve the space um I can't work there
anymore though right you know I don't
even want to have any association um it
has a president that nobody elected it
has events that are filled with um not
good men that are good at being men
they're neither of those things again
some of the information is useful and
it's very very good um I would argue
it's probably better than looking at
data that Evo psych uh Scholars put
together a lot of it is is just uh you
know they're like Stoned on the numbers
you know it's like oh well uh you know I
had um Alex on from daty U you know he's
a Twitter character he has a YouTube
channel as well and he collected some
data on deal breakers you know for
example that um showed up on his surveys
uh from men and women and I was going
through survey results and it was you
know things like um you know broke uh
kind of sloppy appearance bad pictures
you know there's about 35 of them and I
said to them I go dude where is height
on this why did height not show up with
women disqualifying men and he said I
don't know but we know in real life that
women routinely disqualify men based on
height so you can't rely on Evo pych
alone for providing useful information
uh I think you need to plug the people
that are being uh surveyed into um lie
detectors you know because I think that
women have to manage their reputation
they don't want to come off as saying oh
I'm judgmental because of height when
they're asked I mean you see these uh
people interviewed in the street and
they're not always uh you know giving
you the straightforward answers um so
there's a little bit of flaws over there
um but
overwhelmingly there's a PR issue and if
you're not willing to fix the pr issue
and cut out the cancer and remove it
from the space and disassociate from it
it's going to be a [__] space that's
just like like that guy said earlier
over here um where did the Super Chat go
here it was this dude over here is like
it's it's nothing but drama it's drama
it's buy my nft
uh you know buy my uh pickup artist
course on
seduction that guy's a whatever you know
they call each other names all day long
all of these things routinely exist in
this space and I think uh good men that
are also good at being men are tired of
that they just don't want anything to do
with it it's it's it's not their it's
not something that you want to be a part
of I don't want to be a part of it why
the [__] would I want to associate with
guys that you know get rejected by that
say that they have seduction skills but
when they get rejected by women They
smash a glass in the face of the woman
that's not a good man that's not a man
that's good at being a man that's a
piece of [__] why would I want to
associate with somebody that's running
from the law uh or or gets his end users
incarcerated with his systems or hires
prostitutes to you know deceive these
people
again some of the information's good it
really is but if you're not the best
version of yourself if you haven't
leveled yourself up if you haven't done
the work like I say like I talk about in
my book again the chapter on the seven
spokes of a highly uh valuable men make
all the sense that you need to know you
have to be unplugged you have to have
your look sorted you have to have your
money sorted you have to have some
degree of status you have to have a good
amount of game you have to have frame
when it comes to dealing with wom and
you have to have captivation right those
are the seven spokes if you haven't read
the book read the book it's easy to find
right just go to Amazon unplugged Alpha
Rich Cooper you'll find it get the
second edition that's that's the final
and finished
Edition do you understand what I'm
saying like do you guys understand why
you
know I make these statements right I
mean why would anybody want to associate
with a space that has such bad has such
a bad reputation and it continues to
have a bad reputation it's why you'll
never
see I mean never say never you know as I
say but it's why you've never
seen um many of these people on bigname
podcasts like Joe Rogan's podcast right
it's why you'll see uh the academics in
the space tend to dis
disassociate from um these types of
creators you know they call them uh
degenerates they call them um uh incels
they call them nihilistic they call them
uh you know creators of uh
you know these school
shootings um I can't remember the
organization but there was a press piece
that was put out in the last couple
months something along the lines of
where the American government
compared um manosphere
creators uh to
terrorists yeah it happened they the
there's an active organization actually
out there that's aggregated and
categorized the problem uh makers in
that space
and essentially said uh these guys are
as dangerous as terrorists uh they're
radicalizing men uh they use words like
toxic
masculinity um you know all of this uh
stuff and some of it you know like look
man if it walks like a duck and quacks
like a duck like the whole birds of a
feather flock
together if you want to stand out from
the turkeys you got to SAR like an eagle
and that's the problem with the
manosphere they nobody in that space
when I was having the conversations
around look we need to you know set some
standards around here and not [__]
work with some of these retards there
was nobody that was willing to do that
it was like you know I would be on a
panel and there would be somebody on the
panel and be like why is this person
here and the answer I would be get oh
he's you know really good at this that
or the other thing and I would only find
out later what a piece of [__] they were
right so people go well why don't you
you know work in that space anymore it's
because it sucks right it's because
again most of the guys are not good men
or good at being men there's a handful
that I still talk to from time to time
there's a handful that are like hey I
got a new book do you want to talk about
it or hey uh I got a new supplement line
you want to talk about it it's like no
dude I hope you're doing well I want you
to eat I just don't want to eat at the
same table as you in front of people
it's it's just it's not a good look for
me right um I'm on I'm on a different
path I'm on a different Mission I'm
playing a different game um I'm one of
the guys guys that uses his real name
you guys dudes you can go out there and
Google the [__] out of me you won't find
any dirt on me like you'll find on these
other guys that hide behind avatars and
fake names there's a reason why people
use avatars and fake names is because
they have something to
hide and it turns out it's quite a lot
does that make sense have I clarified
things for you guys I
mean I don't think it it can be any
clearer there's a serious PR issue just
like the Christian pillar guys have a
serious PR issue with their Club um the
you know the holier than thou attitude
from the Christian pillars is no
different than the you know our
Solutions better than everybody else
from the Mana swamp or the red pill um
you want to invite people to join your
club and hang out with you and be a part
of it fix it cut out the cancer get rid
of the Riff Raff vet you know your your
uh membership better and stick to a
congruent message um but I tried it
didn't happen so I walked that's why I
don't do that [__] anymore um I'm I'm
adjacent you know people will go oh but
aren't you red pilled Rich sure I've
been red pilled yes I have uh but I see
truth and lies I don't see pill colors I
don't see clubs I don't see I don't see
any of that [__] cuz it's because
it's mostly [__] it's it's some
branding right like everybody's got
their own brand branding myself included
um I'm just very very careful with my
branding and who I want to associate
with and who I'm going to talk to and
the conversations that I want to have um
mine are similar but I am adjacent to it
I am not a part of it I won't be a part
of a [__] circus I won't participate
in a circus and I'm not going to be a
clown for entertainment purposes or for
drama which is what a lot of people seem
to like in that space um so so if that
space that's watching right now cuz I
know a lot of you mofos like to watch my
[__]
still I've made it very clear fix your
[__] it's pretty straightforward fix
your [__] right hold people in your you
know your your your peers that you sit
shoulder-to-shoulder with on panel shows
accountable to standards I get rid of
people that don't that don't stick to my
standards in my community I've I've let
people go over the years oh you want to
collab with those [__] losers okay
make a choice do you want to hang out
with them or do you want to hang out
with the boys right and they've been let
go we don't chat anymore often they'll
come back I've I've kept the screenshots
I've I've got the messages to prove it
often they've come back after the fact
and be like yeah we [__] up is you
know is it cool if we rejoin you know I
think I made a mistake no
no it's pretty straightforward right be
very very clear with your messaging be
impeccable with your word you know it's
an old uh seg segment of the book uh The
Four Agreements um not a fantastic book
but I think a good um you know guide
book overall be impeccable with your
word you know be very clear and
straightforward have I updated my
beliefs over time um sure absolutely
[__] that I believe you know five years
ago I might have changed my opinion on
today um same thing happens from 10
years ago so I'll stand by what I said
at the time
100% um but you won't find uh you know
there's guys that have been incarcerated
because of my work or my book you won't
find uh me running from the law um you
know you won't find news articles and
pieces out there about me smashing a
glass into a girl's face because I've
been rejected you won't find any of that
you know you won't find that I've had uh
Lio lipos suction done to remove belly
fat because I'm too lazy to [__] work
out or change my diet you won't find any
of that you'll find that elsewhere but
you won't find it with me and again not
every Creator in that space is a loser
but almost all the creators in that
space work with these losers to this day
to this day like literally yesterday
somebody forwarded me a clip on a video
of one of the big names in that space
who was bigging up and praising the
piece of [__] that smashed a glass into
a woman's face when he was rejected Okay
so you guys take it for what it's worth
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out